foreign
we will only be here briefly but uh I
watched the most recent interview of Sam
Harris and he once again makes all of
the same uh what I would say are
decidedly wrong points but uh the point
that in the case the 97 I think is the
number he uses of your experts agree and
three percent
uh disagree that yes of course it's
always possible that the non-experts are
right but you should go with the 97
percent of the experts each and every
time because you're um
you're much more likely to be correct in
your thinking and so that's obviously
nuts or I should say it the fact is
obviously nuts but why it's nuts isn't
so obvious and I thought it was worth us
exploring that a little bit
so
um
first of all let me just recall
something that we've talked about here
before which is
um that
it is a if the res the return on
investment for betting Against The
Fringe is pretty reliable right in
general The Fringe isn't right and
um even when it is right it's that
something within the Fringe is Right
while the majority of The Fringe remains
wrong right the fringiness of The Fringe
uh is in and of itself reason to just be
a little skeptical that's certainly true
but what Sam's assertion does not take
into account is a the
disproportionate benefit of knowing when
something on The Fringe is actually
right in spite of the belief of 97 or 99
or effectively 100 of the experts right
in those cases where the experts have it
wrong The Profit to be made is huge
that's one thing
but the other thing is
there's a question about
what that 97 percent even is right under
normal circumstances if everybody was
perfectly free to believe whatever they
wanted and the experts were having
vigorous discussions in which they were
pushing each other around and had
arrived somewhere naturally
then that's not perfect evidence that
they've got it right but it's at least
something
but we don't live in a normal era and
this is really I think what's driving
Sam mad in front of our eyes is that he
is applying rules from some other time
and place as if they are Universal and
they are far from Universal
so
um
what I wanted what I thought was that it
was worth laying out a kind of taxonomy
of uh
of narrative Brokenness right and
looking at what underlies
um
the uh the differences between times and
places and what we ought to put how much
stock we ought to put in the belief of
so-called experts
so I think everybody realizes that we
have a degree of corruption Sam would
acknowledge in fact he repeatedly does
acknowledge
um that
that there is corruption in our
institutions and that that's a problem
but the problem is that the word
corruption itself suggests that it is
the minor Force right if we say that you
know you have an SD card and there's
it's corrupted we're not saying that
most of what's on the SD card is wrong
we're saying that there is a small
disruption somewhere right and that
small disruption may be enough to
prevent your camera from reading it
right or it may distort a photograph or
you know photograph may not be viewable
but the point is the corruption is the
minor part
and the question is are there things
that would cause the Distortion to be
the major part
um
so okay corruption is like you know
well let's try this
in the case that the interests of some
entity that could corrupt the system are
aligned with the interests of the public
in other words if you have a democracy
where the interests of the public are
supposed to to guide
and you have some Corporation and it
wants something done that would actually
be good for the public there's no
problem it doesn't really have to do
anything it can just make the argument
and the public seeing its own interest
will be in support of the thing
that works for the corporation
what that means is that the efforts that
these corporations deploy the expensive
efforts like lobbying for example those
efforts will be in places where their
interests diverge from the public
right it will corrupt the government not
where it doesn't need to do that it will
corrupt the government where it wants
the government not to do the
government's job serving the public but
instead to serve the corporate needs and
so it will disguise those things as if
they are in the interest of the public
I'm a steel man just one one piece of
this which is that
um
lobbying could be simply about getting
the word out so even you know even under
circumstances where all the interests
align which will be somewhat rare you
might still have things like promotion
marketing advertisement lobbying in
order to spread the good word frankly
um I agree at a technical level
um the the problem with that I mean you
you've said you're steel Manning it so I
know you're not advocating this as a as
a major uh countervailing Force but the
problem is it doesn't take almost
anything to spread the word if it's in
the interests of people to hear the word
right if uh you're a representative in
Congress and there's some piece of
legislation that would be beneficial to
both your constituents and to some power
Power Player then it doesn't take very
much to get that in front of you because
hey it's a win for you even cynically
it's a win for you to advance the cause
you'll make yourself more likely to be
reelected you'll have greater power Etc
um and so likewise you know you can say
look there are two reasons for
advertising to exist advertising exists
to manipulate people into doing things
that they wouldn't otherwise do spending
money they wouldn't otherwise spend or
choosing this thing over that thing
um and you can say well part of
advertising is just getting information
out and the answer is yep but sit in
front of your TV sometime and figure out
what percentage of each ad is actually
about information and what percentage is
about manipulation and you'll realize oh
my goodness the Lion's Share of this
thing is absolutely about manipulating
people and the information you know sort
of squeaks in there every now and again
so I think it's like that it's not that
there's no you know a lobbyist could
potentially just alert a lawmaker this
thing is possible and might be good but
more or less what they do really the
reason they're paid the big bucks is to
pretend that that's what they're doing
while in fact they are incentivizing and
manipulating and lying and all of the
things that they're so good at
but okay we got corruption right
corruption takes a system that is
supposed to be rigged around the
interest of the population and it
distorts it right a little bit
then we have the next uh piece of this
taxonomy which is capture right now
capture I want to be careful capture is
a term that often comes with another
term regulatory capture right now in my
opinion that's too narrow regulatory
capture is real and that means that an
industry or a company
has gotten control over some entity that
is supposed to be controlling it right
when a Pharma company gets control of
the FDA right it that has that's the
tail wagging the dog the FDA is supposed
to be protecting us from farm right is
supposed to be exerting control over
them and the reverses happen
um so that's regulatory capture but what
we are seeing is something much broader
than that right because a lot of the
things that have been captured aren't
regulatory right so anyway
when corruption is the minor Force
corruption is the right term capture is
when some entity within the system some
institution or process has been taken
over by something that is supposed to be
subservient to it right and then there's
this next phase where it's not even that
the FDA has been captured by
Pharma but it is actually a whole
network of Institutions that then have
an emergent nature right the FDA has
been captured and the FDA
May Grant uh emergency use authorization
where it shouldn't it may participate in
silencing critics right it may
participate in obscuring harms these
kinds of things these are terrible in
and of themselves but then you find you
know the New York Times playing wingman
yes you do right and so this is like a
whole Next Level not only are we dealing
so corruption is the minor version where
the major version is still doing what
the system is designed to do but it has
been redirected to a small extent you've
got capture where entire institutions
have been inverted and they are doing
the inverse job they are working for
those they are supposed to be regulating
and regulating those they are supposed
to be working for
and then you have this next level thing
which is the emergence of a network of
Institutions that are captured by one
mechanism or another and what it results
is in a an entire
false narrative about where we are what
we face what the experts believe which
is really the place where the analysis
that says hey let's go with the experts
that usually works right we don't know
what the experts believe because as you
and I keep discovering every time you
have a conversation where you confess
your actual beliefs on these things you
find that people don't hold the beliefs
that they have been espousing right they
to one degree or another have private
suspicions that they haven't been
sharing things that they would get
punished if they said them out loud and
so you know we are living in a Hall of
Mirrors that goes even Beyond a world
where you imagine regulatory capture has
happened right why is the New York Times
participating in the same story that the
captured FDA is advancing right how did
that happen how is there no possibility
of real journalism how does it have to
happen in a tweet thread or on sub stack
right rather than in the New York Times
in the Washington Post and you know the
New York Post or whatever other uh
papers I guess the New York Post has
done a certain amount but it's also been
silenced for doing it
um
all right so that's the general General
taxonomy Maybe
the militant moderate writes Sam Harris
would respond favorably to a steel man
off
an initial conversation to Simply nail
down what each of you think sent another
conversation a week or two later
I mean I've offered the man a bunch of
different mechanisms to deal with this I
don't think he could possibly have a
structural objection because the
structure is open uh I think the problem
is he is beginning to detect just how
his heuristic led him into terrible
danger and he's having trouble you know
if you're Sam Harris and you believe all
the things that he keeps saying about
the importance of the institutions
and the discovery that the institutions
have completely collapsed that they are
effectively like the rabid dog
um is a terrifying realization and I
don't disagree that it's terrifying but
I've been trying to tell people for
decades that that's where we were headed
and so this isn't new to me I'm less
terrified because I've gone through the
horrifying thought experiment of what
are we going to do if these institutions
stop working right so I think he's just
getting used to the idea and
um anyway you see some evidence that
it's getting used to the idea
I think
the level at which he has ended up wrong
over the pandemic is going to force him
to realize that some fundamental
assumption has to be off and he's going
to discover that the fundamental
assumption is that there's such a thing
as experts and that they work in
institutions and that those institutions
are uh you know more right than they are
wrong and the answer is no they're more
wiser than they are reality and
Pfizer isn't your friend
you know
yeah it seems like a lot of assumptions
though it's going to be it's a big house
of cards
the man's got himself a house of cards
built on Sand and uh it ain't gonna last
especially with the coming storms so you
know I don't know how many analogies we
have to throw in there
to wake him up but Sam it's time
foreign
[Music]